andré grimaldi professeur émérite de
diabétologie au chu de la pitié
salpêtrière et membre du collectif inter
hôpitaux nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
andré grimaldi bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur rt
france on a entendu un ce médecin a
alerté le chef de l'état sur
l'inquiétude des personnels hospitaliers
dans ce contexte du coronavirus quelle
est votre réaction
mon collègue a raison ça fait dix ans
que l'on fait des économies sur
l'hôpital est aujourd'hui l'hôpital est
tabou c'est à dire qu'il ya des lits
fermés en réanimation faute de personnel
si en plus du personnel est atteint par
la maladie virale sera bien en
quarantaine ce qui se passe à l'hôpital
de creil
donc on risque d'être en manque de
personnel est en manque de lits pour les
patients très graves si l'épidémie se
développe
espérons que va pas se développer mais
si elle se développe l'hôpital est en
tension extrême donc bouclé raison de
dire ses résultats peut-être de dix ans
de politique mais il faut prendre des
mesures d'urgence qui n'ont pas été pris
avec des petites mesures mais très en
deçà des besoins
dès aujourd'hui quelles sont les mesures
qu'il faudrait prendre selon vous a dans
ce contexte du corps navire est
justement là on a entendu à le premier
ministre premières mesures évidentes
c'est qu'il faut arrêter de demander des
économies à l'hôpital public
il était prévu de demander 800 millions
d'économies
alors il ya eu un plan d'urgence où on
donne 200 millions mais ça vient qu'on
demande encore 600 millions d'économies
savez ce qui veut dire diminuer le
personnel ne pas remplacer à secrétaire
qui parlent ne pas remplacer
l'infirmière qui part en retraite
et là il ya besoin de mobiliser du
personnel parce que les délits parce
qu'on ne sait pas quelle peut être
l'ampleur du nombreux patients ayant
besoin d'aller en rénovation vous avez
le sentiment que le chef de l'état était
réceptif justement aux propos de votre
confrère mais je je pense que prénom la
république se dit que si une catastrophe
alors que nous avons injecté
publiquement les politiques en porteront
la responsabilité
la mini se sentait le besoin est parti
mais est reparti avec un échec
seul hôpital public et pars pas avec un
succès selon pisa public donc si
personne ne l'espère on a frôlé la
catastrophe pour les nourrissons avec la
bronchiolite
il y a quelques mois s'il y avait une
catastrophe de réanimation pour le
coronavirus il y aurait directement une
responsabilité politique
donc je pense que prétendent république
et conscience là en tous les cas le
premier ministre lui a annoncé des
mesures ils étaient réunis à matignon
notamment 108 hôpitaux mobilisé en
france 200 millions de masques
supplémentaires voilà ces mesures qu'est
ce qu'elle nous dise de l'épidémie qui
dit vrai je ne suis pas à ce spécialiste
des infections équipes existent tout le
monde sent que pour le moment la
situation est sous contrôle mais qu'elle
peut basculer rapidement
c'était le cas en italie la france a un
système de santé qui tient encore mais
nous sommes à loos la vraie la vraie
question c'est la plupart de ces
affections virales vont être bénigne
mais il ya 1 2 3 % de maladies graves il
faut laisser plusieurs animations s'il
ya des milliers de personnes atteintes
il faut des vies et des personnels
compétents 1 or là nous sommes sous une
tension on a évité de justesse une
catastrophe au mois d'octobre et
novembre
il ya donc eu il ya suffisante dépistage
enfin non seulement vous du conte à un
virus je suis incapable de vous répondre
parce que moi je suis diabétologue où je
vois que mes collègues infectiologues
suivre ça de très près l'ensemble de la
communauté médicale elle est mobilisée
alors après on peut toujours savoir cris
critiques etc
si on en fait trop on dira c'est un
missile sont en fait pas assez
ce qui est sûr c'est que je voulais
c'est comme quand tu y as le les
pompiers on les mobilise pas seulement
quand elle veut il faut que l'hôpital
soit prêt or on a traité l'hôpital comme
une entreprise qui devaient travailler
en fusion du nom un hôpital doit avoir
des villes et les personnels parce que
il ya des urgences alors cette sergent
sans plus à la particulière parce
qu'elle peut contaminer les soignants je
vous redis à creil les soignants sont en
quarantaine à décines particulière
justement aujourd'hui donnée aux
soignants il ya un vrai dialogue entre
le ministère de la santé et les hôpitaux
et les autres en public il semble t'il
suffisant ou pas je suis pas directement
concerné je peux pas vous répondre je
pense que tout le monde est conscient et
compris les hommes politiques du risque
politique cette fois ci qu'il prenne
indépendamment du fait du risque pour la
population
donc voilà la situation et qu'on peut
pas traiter l'hôpital comme une
entreprise rentable travailleurs un flux
tendu donc sur la situation actuelle je
ferai pas de critique politique girona
le résultat il faut que le présent la
république prenne l'occasion de dire
l'hôpital ne peut pas être traité comme
il a été traité en or pour le moment
l'assemblée nationale avait voté un
budget de 800 millions de l'économie
alors il ya eu une rallonge de 200
millions mais on est loin du compte et
le chronobus risque de faire exploser la
situation
c'est un risque votre confrère disait
justement au chef de l'état c'est
maintenant ou jamais qu'il faut agir
c'est maintenant parce qu'il a une
opportunité de dire les règles sont pas
des règles budgétaires habituel il ya
une exception il faut un correctif
budgétaire pour l'hôpital il a
l'occasion de le faire et pour nous sera
important sera important pour savoir si
on dira ce quinquennat a fait comme les
précédents il a mis l'hôpital public par
terre parce qu'on arrive à bout le
numéro deux du ministre de la santé
jérôme salomon alors tu es aussi sur le
rôle des
des réseaux sociaux dans ce contexte de
crise du coronavirus est-ce que
effectivement quoi finalement avoir peur
un peu en ce moment où il faut pas céder
non plus à la panique qui selon le
professeur dans la panique il faut
suivre ce qui est dit comme précaution
entre lavage des mains éviter les lieux
de rassemblement on n'a pas besoin
d'être bon tout ça et est quasiment du
bon sens
non le problème c'est que si elle
démarre épidémique
il y aura des porteurs sains qui
transporte la maladie qui la prend 1
on ne saura pas qui sont porteurs et
donc là on a un vrai problème et non le
ce problème encore cédé 3 ou 4 % de
personnes qui doivent à leur animation
est ce qu'on aura les lie le personnel
pour faire face si parce que pour le
moment la maladie beaucoup moins grave
que la grippe elle-même 1,1 des
problèmes d'ailleurs en france c'est que
beaucoup de personnel qui fréquentent
des personnes âgées ne sont pas vaccinés
donc ça nous fait réfléchir aussi
voilà donc la main a dit pour le moment
est moins grave que la grippe mais elle
peut exploser alors qu'on n'a pas de
traitement
merci beaucoup andré grimaldi d'avoir
partagé votre analyse je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur émérite de
diabétologie au chu de la pitié
salpêtrière et membre du collectif inter
hôpitaux